good morning everyone so let's get
started with the final day of the
workshop uh the first talk will be on
homomorphism counts by colitis
the floor thank you very much uh
good morning let me thank the organizers
for this opportunity and honor to be
here and speak on this workshop on
satisfiability Theory practice and
Beyond
I highlighted the Beyond
and the more I think about it the more
ambiguous this name looks to me because
that's beyond mean Beyond theory and
practice
in which case I have nothing to say or
does it mean beyond sad and I hope it
means beyond sad and in fact this would
be Theory Beyonce
and let's start by going well beyond sad
and here is a quote and a quiz
let me read the quote
mathematicians study not objects but
relations between objects the
replacement of this object by others is
therefore indifferent to them provided
the relations do not change
the matter is for them unimportant
the form alone interested
any guesses as to who and when this was
written
No actually that's a big very good guess
very good guess but it is about 50 years
before Alexander graftondick is by
Enrique
1902 from his book science and
hypothesis in the English translation he
was 48 years old at the time he died 10
years later prematurely
and I have emphasized here the
replacement of these objects by others
is therefore indifferent to them
provided the relations do not change
what could he possibly mean I think
there is only one interpretation and
this is argued that in mathematics we
study objects up to isomorphism
and what I mean by asomorphism here I
don't need to tell you a definition I
have in mind isomorphism between
regressional structures which is the
case of graphs means there is a function
that's one to one and don't do from the
notes of the first graph to the nodes of
the other graph which preserves edges
both ways
now the reality is that in mathematics
we study objects up to some other
equivalence relation sometimes its
equivalence relation is
omorphism in Disguise sometimes it's not
for instance topologist General topology
classify topological spaces up to
homeomorphism
in differential geometry we have the
study of different morphism and one
could argue that these are the Notions
of isomorphism for these types of
objects
but we have all sorts of Logics
including first order logic and in logic
we study equivalence of two structures
in some logic meaning they satisfy the
same sentence of the logic in the case
of finite structures and first or the
logic
first order equivalent is the same as
isomorphism that's a trivial exercise or
a well-known exercise in every logic
book but when you go to infinite
structures logical equivalence and
isomorphism go different ways
so here we will be focusing on
equivalence relations that arise from
the notion of homomorphism
so let me remind you of what we mean
homomorphism again for concreteness I
will do it for graphs but it's easy to
see how to do it for arbitrary
relational structures so a homomorphism
from a graph to another is a function
from the nodes of the first to the nodes
of the second that it preserves edges
from left to right this means if I have
an edge in me in an energy indeed then
the image of this Edge after after under
the homomorphism is energy net
so it relaxes the notion of isomorphism
in two ways the function is not required
to be a one one to one and don't do and
the preservation of addresses from left
to right not also from right to left
let's make it concrete
uh take an arbitrary graph and take the
click with three elements the triangle
graph
there is a homomorphism
from K3 to G event only if G contains a
triangle
on the other hand if we flip things
around
and we ask what does it mean we have a
homomorphism from G to K3 this means
that the graph is recolorable
because we don't have self-loops the
requirement to go to different edges to
edges to be not connected by an S we
have a different colors it's precisely
we have a homomorphism the preservation
of here this is obviously generalizes to
all finite clicks
now the notion of homomorphism between
two graphs is not an equivalence
relation chromomorphism is composed so
that's a transitive relation and it's
also obviously reflexive but it's not
symmetric we can symmetrize it and that
we have the fundamental notion of
homomorphic equivalence which means that
we have homomorphisms going both ways
from G to H and from H to D
let's go back to our running example
let's uh one of examples here if I have
two color of graphs with at least one
Edge each then they are homomorphically
equivalent because they are
homomorphically equivalent to the edge
in particular the cycle with four
elements and the cycle with six elements
are homomorphically equivalent
so this is an important equivalence
relation a relaxation of isomorphism we
will not slide it per se but it will
play at all specially in the second part
of this talk
uh so in summary homomorphic equivalence
is an equivalence relation coarser than
isomorphism
unlike isomorphism whose computational
complexity remains still one of the open
Major open problems of theoretical
computer science we know the complexity
of homomorphic equivalence it's nnp
complete it's obviously an NP because we
can get the two homomorphisms from G to
H yes
so
it is in NP because you can guess the
two homomorphisms from G to H and from H
to G and it can be hard because a graph
is recolorable if and only if the joint
Union of the graph G with a triangle is
homomorphic equivalent to the triangle
in fact the homomorphic equivalence
class of the triangle are all three
color graphs that contain a triangle if
you only have a concrete chromomorphic
equivalence class in mind
now we come the central notion of this
talk which is the notion of the number
of homomorphs
from G to H and following the
standard notation that people like
bubble hell and yeah recognized reviews
we're gonna indicate homomorphism with
lower age home G8 is the number of
homomorphisms from G to eight
concrete examples again back to the
graph arbitrary graph G and the triangle
the number of homomorphisms from K3 to G
is the number of triangles
that we can find in z
on the other hand the number of
homomorphisms from G to K3 is the number
of three colorings
okay so we're adding two model counties
here
and let me take this a little bit
further
and
try to share with you two different
views of this homomorphism counts
one view comes from considering
satisfaction
so what is the constraint satisfaction
problem I will
presented here the way it was formalized
by federal and vardin that celebrated
1993 paper uh where they looked at the
constraint satisfaction problem as a
family of decision problems one for
every relational structure so if I have
a relational structural age the graph if
you will for concreteness CSP of AIDS is
the question given a graph is that a
homomorphism from G to H and we can
identify it with a model class of all
graph G for which there is a
homomorphism from g28 therefore when we
have this perspective when we fix Edge
home GH is the number of solutions
of the constraint satisfaction problem
so for instance if H was a finite
structure encoding
the structure used to encode 3cnf is the
number of solutions to a 3D CNF formula
the number of satisfying assignments
there is another perspective
which if you are not familiar with
database Theory may be new to you
every relational structure
gives rise to a conjunctive query what
is a conjunctive query a conjunctive
query is a Formula first order logic
which is a bunch of existential
quantifiers followed by conjunction of
atomic formulas
so in the case of the triangle again the
conjunctive query is called the
canonical consent query says there are
three nodes and three variables and we
have vxy and e y z and vzx
logicians know this concept under the
name positive Atomic diagram and make
sense for both finite and different
instruction but in the case of finite
Direction turn it into a formula first
or the logic another name for this
formula that is primitive positive you
may have seen that in that context
okay
now it is easy to verify
that if you fix G and you look at home
G8 this is the number of satisfying
assignments from the canonical
conjunctive query associated with Z to
inputate is the number of ways in which
and inputate satisfies this conjunctive
query
and if you think about this what is
going on here these are the so-called
back semantics or multi-set semantics of
a square
because if you write a select from where
clause in SQL
you're gonna get
perhaps a title is with multiplicities
multiced and the wonderful introduction
of multisets is in volume 2 of Professor
who knows a book art of computer
programming with some history of the
movie sets so these are two different
views and it's the same object right but
you can you have to look at it this way
either as Solutions number of solutions
to the concerning satisfaction problem
or number of satisfying assignments of
the conjunctive query so these are the
two perspectives one question yes
so on the previous slide you had that um
you want to count or the number of
triangles but are you accounting each
triangle one sorry counting it six times
I'm
six times here okay no okay Dennis yeah
but thanks that's a good point
all right now let's try to visualize
this common morphism counts imagine an
infinite
Matrix where we have listed on the rows
and the columns
graphs and we pick one graph from every
isomorphic equivalence class so it is
what Stefan zeider called the other day
isomorphyrie doesn't really matter for
but let's assume we have picked up from
every equivalence class only uh one
graph so we create this
we say infinite infinitable
and now let's do the following thing
let's put ourselves
on some column
here so this is a column index by Sum
graph G and let's go down this column
what we see we count the homomorphism
from G1 to G from G2 to G from g to g
and so on and so forth if we take this
infinite vector
we get the notion of the left profile of
G
so the left profile of G is the vector
consisting of all homomorphism counts
from all other graphs
but of course we can switch perspectives
and go
in the row that corresponds to G and
travel along is wrong
and then what we see we see the
homomorphism from G to G1 the number of
homologies from Z to G2 and so on and so
forth and we call this the right profile
of
and with these Notions of the left
profile and the right profile we can now
state two very well known results and
let's start with Lopez's theorem
was barely 19 years old or 18 years old
at the time that's one of his first
papers he proved that two graphs G and
dates are isomorphic if and only if they
have the same left profile
so this is very it's not a difficult
result but it's very interesting because
it makes a very tight connection between
number of homomorphisms and isomorphisms
clearly
it's its count is an invariant of
hormone of the homologous equivalence
class and this tells you if I take the
entire Vector of all counts then that
capsules isomorphs at the level of our
table
it really says that no two columns are
the same right
if I had allowed the same graph to the
grass from the same equivalent as class
to occur in them in the in this table
then it would say that two columns are
equal if and only if the graphs arise
right but since we have picked isomer
free this means not to columns are equal
now you may Wonder okay we did this from
The Columns what happened from the rows
well we have the same result I like to
call this uh that's how to rivardi
theorem
even though lovers turns out was aware
of this a few years later
and now what do childhood involved in
1993 had to do with them homologous
accounts nothing they published a paper
in the database conference pods
and they looked at the back semantics of
conjunctive queries now here is where we
have to remember recall the previous
perspective that I shared with you so
there is access to graphs are isomorphic
event only if they have the same right
profile
but you see what is the right profile
the right profile is a number of
satisfying assignments of the canonical
conjunctive query on Z
so this says that two graphs are
isomorphic if and only if their
canonical conjunctive queries have the
same
semantics under the maximums
so the two queries are equivalent in the
sense of back semantics and that's what
they proved there they are interested
they initiated the study of
queries in databases under box semantics
so this is where the two perspectives
are useful and now again this says that
no two rows are equal in that infinite
Matrix that we have
all right so we have the notion of
isomorphism capsuled by left and the
right profiles
now let's do
the following
thing
suppose I have a class of graphs your
favorite class of graphs
and now instead of looking at the entire
profile left or right
I only restrict
the profile to the graphs coming from
that class
so for instance I can talk about the
left profile of zero selector 12 is the
vector home FG home f1g home F2 G Etc
where F1 F2 come from the class F and
graphic F that I have fixed
in some sense what this says we go down
the column and we only keep the rows
that arise from graphs in F
again if you have the table in mind you
throw out all the rows that don't come
from don't arise from graphs enough
and of course again we can do the same
thing from the right we can talk about
the right profile of G restricted to F
is the vector home GF home gf1 Etc home
gf2 we only keep the columns that arise
from graphs in F
so we have with a hormone account
and a class of graphs we have introduced
these Notions of profiles the left
profile and the right profile
but now you see once you have such a
class you get new equivalence relations
so every class of graphs gives rise to
two equivalent relations which are
relaxations of isomorphism
what are these equivalence relations
the left equivalence relation says two
graphs are equivalent if they have the
same left profile restricted wave
two graphs are equivalent if they have
the same profile restricted to F that's
the same right profile receipt that's
the second equivalence equation both
these equivalence relations are
relaxations of isomorphins
and now of course the natural question
that arises is what are these
equivalence classes do we get any
interesting equivalence classes this way
and now we also have a notion of
expressive power
because we can look at all left profiles
restricted and all the restricted right
profiles and see how do they compare
is it the case that everything we can do
with the left profile we can do with
some right profile and vice versa
so is the left better than the right is
the right better not the left already
about the same
foreign
explain the first result in this
line of of work
I want to bring in I need to bring in
some logic
these are counting Logics with finally
many variables these have been
arguably one of the most extensively
studied Logics in finite model theory
for the past 30 or 40 years
the idea is
that you start with first order logic
and we restrict the number of areas you
can use because you think of variables
occupy some cells in memory and you want
to restrict how many variables you have
to use you can reuse a variable many
times
so the same variable may occur many
times but the total number of distinct
variables is K
now let's take this logic and add some
counting ability to it and this is first
order logic with counting quantifiers CK
and accounting quantifiers have this
form there exists iwise and the meaning
of a of a statement exists i y v of y
means there are there are at least I
nodes such that three or four icons
no
elements of the universe of the
structure and for graphs for vertices of
the graph
in general if I'm if I have a relational
structure remind you the elements of the
universe of the structure
so example the graph is seven regular
this property you can Define in the
counting logic with two quantifiers you
will do variables because you can say
for every X there are seven y's that are
connected to X and it is not the case
there are eight y's that are connected
to seven on the other hand if you are to
spell this out you will need eight you
need eight variables so here you can do
it with only two variables if you allow
discounts
there is a very early paper by Thai
fidelimerman
that had several results this is not the
most important result in the paper but
it's perhaps very fundamental
it related equivalence in discounting
logics
to
indistinguishability by a very well
known heuristic for graphisomorphism
revised file a lemon algorithm
which is also known as the color
refinement algorithm I'm not going to
discuss these algorithm but I just want
to point out they found this connection
between
indistinguishability in the logic with
counting the
quantifiers and
indistinguishability via this heuristic
for graph isomerset the theorem says
there are two graphs are CK equivalent
satisfy the same sentences of the
counting logic with K variables if and
only if if and don't leave you cannot
tell them apart
by the K minus one dimensional vice
versa lemon algorithm the one
dimensional is also known as the vertex
refinement called refinement
so that's very excited email result and
now let's go back to homomorphisms this
is the result yes
so you're allowing people
yes
I guess it could also be eliminated
um do people ever this is this powerful
enough to count pairs could you count
the number of pairs y z for this
language
you can count
we do that
is the language but it's just probably
expressible it's expressible you can
express
well that's all that's been like
so when we're coming now to the first
important result
and this was by standing forzak in 2010
it's a beautiful result
out of the blue he proved that two
graphs
are indistinguishable in their first
order counting logic with K variables if
and only if they have the same left
profile restricted to the class of
graphs of three with less than k
now uh most of you should be familiar or
are familiar with the Nelson the three
with very quickly it's a positive
integer the three width of a graph is a
positive integer that somehow tells us
how far away from being a tree the
graphics
so three skip three with fine Cycles
have three with two and clicks far away
from trees have three width and minus
one the notion has been very fundamental
in two ways in many ways but including
the he has played a major role in the
graph minor theorem of uh simmer and
Robinson and second we have many
algorithmic meta theorems to the effect
like cool cell CRM that says that if you
take an arbitrary formula of magnetic
secondary logic in general the model
checking problem could be NP complete
but on graphs of boundary width it is in
polynomial time
so this
uh this is some background on three
weeks and this result makes this
unexpected connection that satisfying
the same sentences of
CK is the same as having the same left
profile restricted to the class of three
with less than k v yes
but also
because the other characterization in
terms of being indistinguishable by this
heuristic
foreign
who also had new results here is one of
them two graphs are called spectral if
they're adjacent matrices have the same
Spectrum meaning the same multicent of
eigen values
so this is the first example the
smallest example of two graphs
that are not isomorphic but are spectral
this is the cycle The Joint Union with
an isolated node and the star graph
point in the middle and for for is
coming out the spectrum is minus two
zero zero zero zero with multiplicity
three and two
if they have the same left profile
restricted to the class of all Cycles
and this is a very nice result I think
because it takes the equivalence
relation which has been extensively
studied in algebraic graph Theory like a
cross-spectrality and tells you that it
can be captured
by homomorphism counts but this time you
have to change the restricting class
here we are restricting on the class of
all Cycles
so this was the state of affairs and and
um we have seen that the restricted
leftover files can capture interesting
relaxations of isomorphism so with
Alberta's areas and my student weilyn Wu
at UC Santa Cruz we address the
following question this is happening on
the left what happens to the right can
we characterize this equivalence
relations by restricted right profiles
and that I do as well as the left
doesn't have to be the same class it's
okay to use a different description
as if it has to see where we are
as regards isomorphism we can use the
class of all graphs and then we can
capture it to the left and the right
profiles for CK equivalence and cost
spectrality we can capture them by
restricting two graphs of three with
less than K into Cycles so the question
is can this CK equivalence and
cross-spectorality be capsule by
restricted right profiles and the answer
is no
so this is a lower boundary result if
you will a negative expressibility
result that none of these equivalence
relations can be captured by restricted
right profile
so this is a strong statement there is
something you can do from the left but
you cannot do from the right
and
in fact this is a consequence of the
following theorem
that if I have an arbitrary equivalence
relation of graphs
which is sandwiched between C1
equivalence and CK equivalence so it's
finer than C1 equivalence this is
indistinguishability in the counting
logic with one variable
but coarser than CK equivalence
instability
the equivalence than two then
none of these equivalence relations can
be captured by a right profile yes
so is there a reason left was studied
more than provide does look like people
are interested in the left I think
there's a lot of assist here just
because the lowest theorem became very
late in 1967 it's practical in every
textbook is
there and also he has the connection to
consensus attraction as much as
currently been under uh also used the
right profile and for me at least coming
from database here is the maximum index
of conjunctive queries
for me
thanks for the questions all right
that's the only explanation I have I
don't know if there's more profound
explanations
just a collection of guys collection of
graphs can't you use that to define the
class of autographs if I put the glass
that comes with isomorphins
Kiera here I don't care by so much
yeah
understand
I have some equivalent relational graphs
and I want to know if there is some
collection of graphs yes so that
to the left side equivalent if and don't
leave my two graphs have the same
homological accounts restricted to this
class this collection
right
no because you can say that everybody is
out we want to show that there is no
satisfied
but I'm saying this
country we play three and H to bt4 or
something like this and see that you
have to be all
the graphs I have the same number of
homomorphisms
may not express the equivalence
relationship I'm starting with an
equivalent language I'm stuck I'm
someone gives me an equivalency
okay I'm sorry
thank you
so as I said you should think of this as
a negative result as a lower bound
result it tells you that none of these
equivalent relations sandwiched between
uh C1 equivalent and CK equivalence are
captured by restricted profiles on the
right
let me give you a bird's eye view of
what's going on here we proceed by
contradiction there is a
trivial case and the non-trivial case so
we assume that there is such a
collection of graphs
that capsule this equivalence relation
in the sense that two graphs are
equivalent in this event only if we have
the same right profile distributed well
there is lazy case is where every graph
in F is two colored
then we can immediately arrive a
contradiction because we take the click
with three elements and they click with
four elements we can tell them apart
with a counting with one variable
therefore
they are not equivalent in the sense of
our equivalence relation
uh on the other hand because neither K3
nor K4 are too colorable they give us
the same answer zero for every two color
graph in particular they have the same
right profile
therefore they ought to be equivalent
but this cannot happen
um because we have we have assumed that
yeah this this cannot happen
all right so now we've got the
interesting case where there is a non
two color graph and that requires some
work
there is a beautiful theorem in the
study of constraint satisfaction that
preceded the federal dichotomy Federal
conjecture and the federal and the
solution of the federal conjecture by
zuk and bullet off in 2017 and this is
the dichotomy theorem by Helen nezatril
they said that for undirected graphs
if the graph is too colorable then the
concerning satisfaction problem is in
polynomial time that's easy
the difficult part to prove was that if
the graph is not colorable to colorable
then the constraint satisfaction problem
is NP complete
so for considering satisfaction and
undirected graphs the dividing line is
to collability
from the work that has been done in
considering satisfaction we are able to
extract a defined up dichotomy theorem
and the Define of dichotomy CRM tells
you that this
dichotomy exists also at the level of
logical definability
if the graph is too correl then the
constraint satisfaction problem with
respect weights is definable in the
negation of data log I'm not going to
explain these terms
the important part for us and this this
was well known the important part is
that the graph is not colorable to
colorable then the constraint
satisfaction problem is not definable
in an extension of the counting logic
which has M variables but it allows for
arbitrary conjunctions and disjunctions
you allow for infinitated Junctions in
conjunctions this is quite powerful it
can express least fixed Point logic with
counting and so on so in some sense this
tells you that even if P turns out to be
equal to NP in which case a dichotomy
collapses
there is still
a difference
between
age being too collable and that's not
being too color up at the level of
definability that's a provable dichotomy
that doesn't use any complexity
assumptions
that's the tool we need
because once we have that
you assume that the graph cont the class
F contains a non-to-color graph H star
therefore but the Define of the
dichotomy theorem
the constraint satisfaction problem on
it star is not CK Infinity definable
for k
is
remember our equivalence relation
sandwich between a one C1 equivalence
and CK equivalence
because it's not defined up there this
means there are two graphs one
has a homomorphism plates that the other
does not have a homomorphism to 8 star
but they are CK equivalent therefore
they are also
equivalent in the sense of our
equivalence relation since our
equivalence relation is coarser than CK
equivalence and now we are done because
since
g0 is in CSP of 8 star this means there
is a homomorphism the hormone income is
positive
because they are equivalent
in the sense of our equivalence relation
they hear the same homogeneous account
but they can't have the same component
in the count it can be positive because
G1 is not in CSP 8 star and therefore it
must have the count must be zero so you
put all these things together and you
get the dichotomy you you get you get
the sandwich the sandwich theorem which
says again that if I have an equivalence
relation of graphs that is finer than C1
is equivalence and coarsity than CK
equivalence no class of graphs F
here's the property that the right
profile
restricted to this class capsules this
equivalence equation and what we get out
of this uh we get what we are after in
the beginning for every K bigger or
equal than two there is no class of
graphs such as the right profile
distributed left capture CK equivalence
you also get that there is no class of
graphs so the right profile restricted
to have capsules called spectrality
because it is a well-known factor that
cross-spectorality is sandwiched between
C1 equivalence and and C3 equivalence
in the counting logic
so you get these two results and many
others in um as correlates of this CRM
and
now
you can say well look this is one more
case where the left has the superiority
over the right
not so fast
not so fast the ride Strikes Back
so
we have seen limitations on the right
profiles now let me show you a
limitation of the left profile
there is a well-known equivalence
relation yes so just a question does it
make sense to ask the same uh question
with respect to CK Prime and CK
you know negative results
well you you have this equivalence
relation that sort of in between C1 and
CK yes and then you have this negative
result yes so what if it's in between CK
Prime and CK for K Prime less than k
does it make sense to us
oh I see what you're saying
uh
we we no not enough this because if it
is still between C1 and CK Prime right
so it's still not captured
okay
there is another fundamental equivalence
relation
which is chromatic equivalent
two graphs are chromatically equivalent
if they have the same number of n
columns
for every end
this is a very old equivalent relation
was introduced in 1912
by George David bilkov
that's not the book of the McLean book
of
category Theory it's the father of
garden
HSP this is his father also known for
his work on the ergotic theorem he
introduced this notion because she was
trying to use it to prove the Four Color
theorem back in 1912.
and um
chromatic equivalence is very easily
captured
by the right profiler is directed to the
class of clicks we have seen this
already in some sense
because for all graphs we have that they
are chromatically equivalent if and only
if they have the same number of
homomorphisms to every click
now we can solve using iron for it for I
say games that there is no class of
graphs so that the left profile
restricted to the class uh capture
schematic equivalence so this is
something you can do from the right you
capture natural equivalent selection
that we are not captured from the left
and in summary what we have seen here is
this picture
isomorphism caps with both left and
right
CK equivalence cosplay targeted capsule
from the left but not from the right
chromatic equivalence is captured from
the right but not from the left
and then there are some other
fundamental equivalences arising from
Logic for instance this is a 4K
equivalence no counting it has first
order the logic with K variables and
this is the iron void freset equivalence
Quantified depth K we're looking at two
structures being equivalent if they
satisfy the same person the sentences of
quantifier adapt K which is the same as
saying the duplicator wins the
um Erin Floyd FedEx game with K moves on
these two structures uh for this neither
the left nor the right
works there is no restriction that gives
you this equivalence on the left no
restriction that gives you the
equivalence ablation of the right
so this is the this is the summary and
now in the remaining 10 minutes or so I
want to discuss
um the second part of the talk
last year there was a paper by 10 Flume
Leo and Zan
who introduced the framework
for testing membership in a class using
finitely many homomorphism counts
so we have some collection of graphs you
can think of it as a property of graphs
and you want to test if a graph has this
property
and you are allowed to ask queries that
involve homo mortgage accounts that's
the idea
let me give you a definition and say
something more about the definition
so
the definition says that if I have a
collection of structures
we say that this admits a left query
algorithm over the same meaning of the
natural numbers
if there exists a positive industry K
and there are structures F1 FK and some
said
X subset when to the K so that whatever
structure d z belongs to the class if
and only if
this finite left profile belongs to X
that's the definition
how should we think about this there is
um a lot of work in database Theory
where we try to we don't have access to
all the data
we can only ask about certain patterns
concerning the data this is a whole area
called answering queries using views for
instance okay this is
evaluation of this where you want to
test membership in the class C or
wherever your Guardians the property
and all you are allowed is to ask
homomorphins accounts against the fixed
collection of structures
so you want to use this common modeling
account to test for membership in the
class
it is easy to verify
that the notion
of having a left query algorithm over
the same meaning of the natural numbers
is the same as saying there is a finite
class
of structures
so that for all structures and dates if
they have the same left profile or
distributed to the class F then one is
in C and only if the other Regency so
it's invariant under this equivalence
relation of having the same left profile
are restricted to this class
here is the 10 and Flume definition
again
and here is uh here are a couple of
results that they prove
they studied uh also the notion of a
right query algorithm exactly as we saw
before I'm not going to repeat the
definition now you look at the homo
modules accounts from the right
they saw that if you have a collection
of graphs definable by Boolean
combination of universal first order
sentences so first order sentences
negations of Festival sentences
conjunctions in Junctions such things
every such class admits a left query
algorithm
but you cannot do this from the right
we saw that the class of all triangle
free graphs does not admit a right query
algorithm
this is actually quite interesting yes
intuition behind the K here what they
think of as a k
EPT it is how many how many homomorphism
questions can you ask
you have this fixed collection of grams
and there is a difference if you can ask
two or three or five questions actually
you can show it's a parameterization
according to the number of K but here
we're going we're aiming for negative
results and or or so we decayed we want
to sort of something doesn't exist for
all K or exists for some K and then
worry about how long can go with the
cake
actually because
let me say something about again
something we can do from the left not to
from the right in the federal Verde
um constellation satisfaction paper
all right yes uh why can't you write K
color or k equivalents chromatic
equivalence as a universal first order
sentence you can write K color ability
as a counting sentence couldn't you I
can again I can express cake
colorability very good I can express
ability from the right in a trivial way
in fact in fact if I what I can do from
the right are Boolean combinations of
csps
okay but that's not three colorability
here it is that all the graphs that are
triangle free this is natural
colorability it's the collection of
graphs that omit a triangle I have more
men for part one
um in the previous at the end of the
last section part one the part one is
about is about what I can do from the
left at the end of the last section you
said that K that chromatic equivalent
was not did not have a left query
algorithm right no I said something
different
that there is no there is no a class of
graphs so that with the class can be
infinite here
plus can be infinite okay thank you
thank you
okay so I was saying that in the federal
party paper on um concerning
satisfaction and monotone monadic strict
NP they point out that the class
of all triangle free graphs
is not equivalent to any CSP problem you
cannot write it as a CSP problem
and for this you use erdosstrm that
there are graphs of arbitrary large
chromatic number and get
this is a strengthening of this result
it tells you not only you cannot write
it as a CSP but even if you use Counting
solutions to CSP problems you can still
cannot express and finitely many
accounts
concerning CSP problems so there is
something to something to be proved here
and they prove that
so very recently with balderd and cut in
Amsterdam because
Santa Cruz we studied the paper that of
a 10 influence we saw before and we did
two things
uh we decided to go beyond the same
meaning of the natural numbers and
consider the other important symmetry
the symboling of the Boolean
values zero and one
and we started query algorithms over the
Boolean summary and then we became
interested in comparing uh what does
counting really give you is there a
difference counting over the Boolean or
counting over the natural numbers
what do I mean counting over the Boolean
well counting over the Boolean home FD
is either one or zero if there is either
if there is a homomorphism is one if
there is no harm morphism is zero
and now we can say that the class of
structures admits a left query algorithm
over the Boolean summary
if there are structures F1 f2fk and some
set X so D is in the class if and don't
leave
the left profile restricted to F1 FK is
in X but now this is a Boolean Vector
right this tells you there is a hormone
there is no hormone
so the first result that we have a
completely characterizes the class of
structures that admit the left query
algorithm over the Boolean
and the the result says it admits a left
query algorithm over B
if and only if it is defined by a
Boolean combination of conjunctive
queries if and only if
it's first or the defined and closed
under homomorphic equivalent Clause
under homographic equivalence means
exactly what the term suggests that if
you have a structure in the class and we
have another one which homomorphically
equivalent to it then the second one is
option begins
now one implies two implies three
straightforwards from the definitions
the interesting direction is three
implies one and this is these uses tools
by Ben Rosman
who in 2005 proved one of the remaining
open problems in the model theory of
highlight model Theory preservation
under homomorphisms in the finite
immediate corollary is that if you start
with a class that you know is closed
under homomorphic equivalence then this
admits a left query algorithm over the
booleans if and only if it's first order
defined up two important special cases
are CSP
and in some sense that's a strengthening
of a result that Albert had even before
the rosman's theorem and
every homomorphic equivalence class is
clearly
closed under homologous equivalence
tells you the only ones that admit
a left query algorithm over the booleans
are the ones that are first ordered
defined
so this clarifies completely the picture
what you can do over the Boolean
assembling
now let's compare what you can do over
the Boolean
versus what you can do with the natural
numbers
it is very straightforward to see that
if you have a left query algorithm over
the Boolean then you get the left query
algorithm over the natural numbers
it's also easy to see that you may admit
the left query algorithm over the
natural numbers but not over B
for example takes it with a glass of
grass with at least 7 or 27 or any
number of edges this is easy to see you
can do it over the natural numbers but
not over the booleans so it looks like
the natural language can do more but
this is an unfair comparison why is it
an unfair comparison because
you see if
the class admits a left query algorithm
over the booleans then it must be closed
under homomorphic equivalence
so but this class is not closed under
homographic equivalence so the question
is
what happens if we create 11 playing
field and we ask I have a class of
structures it's caused under homomorphic
equivalence does it make a difference
if I use counting over the natural
numbers as opposed to over the booleans
so that's counting by me anything when
it over existence as it as regards
classes that are closed under
homomorphic equivalence in particular
what can we say about csph
what can we say about
the homomorphic equivalence classes we
saw before that over the booleans the
only
ages for which
um csph
he has a left with algorithm are the
ones that are first ordered Define them
can I get a known for defined at the
cspa it's like that meets a left query
algorithm over the natural numbers so we
uh balder tankate and I were struggling
with this we headed for the
CSP we headed for the equivalence
homework equivalence classes we did not
know how to do the general case then
Victor dalmao came into the picture and
he produced a very beautiful solution to
this problem and the result is that for
classes that are closed under
homomorphic equivalence there is no
difference between the booleans and the
natural numbers whatever you can do over
the national numbers you can also do a
very booleans and left query algorithms
uh I'll take one minute and suggest the
the idea here
the idea is first of all there are two
ideas one is you so the interesting
Direction how you go from the natural
numbers to the booleans how do you
neutralize the power of counting
well
so we want to prove that one implies
true so we take this at x with the
subset of n to the K and we write it as
a The Joint Union of basic sets what is
a basic set is a set where if one of the
tuples have a zero in one coordinate
then every other member in the set has a
zero in the same chord
yeah
when you do this and you start we
receive that meets a left query
algorithm over the natural numbers then
what happens is that this decomposition
gives rise to classes that are closed
under homomorphic equivalence that's
easy to check so it boils down to the
following thing suppose is closed under
homomorphic equivalence and admits a
left query algorithm over the natural
numbers
then it admits
a left with the argument over the
booleans because it is definable
by this conjunction of conjunctive
queries and negations of conjunctivities
and what are the conjunctive ways they
want the condemnity queries such as in
the corresponding position in the tuples
we have not zero and in all the others
we have zero remember we're working with
the basic set so this is the part that
requires quite a bit of work
and um that in turn breaks into three
parts
so
the difficult part is suppose you take
a structure that satisfies this William
combination of conjunctive queries we
want to prove that it's in the class C
where C is closed under homework
equivalence admits a left query
algorithm of the natural numbers
what you do is you take some habit some
set a in the classy and you construct a
prime and B Prime where a prime is at
the Joint Union of many copies of a that
many will come from the three from the
third part
and at the Joint Union of direct
products of members of F and
subtractions of members of faith and
similarly for B Prime so these are
The Joint unions of many copies of a
together combinations of structures of f
and substance
you arrange things so that means a prime
and B Prime have a property that a prime
is homomorphic equivalent to a and b
Prime is homomorphic equivalent to B and
then the homomorphic counts of a prime
and B Prime are the same with respect to
F in the sense of the natural numbers
this uses a polynomial interpolation
result and the polynomial interpolation
result tells you how many copies you
must use and now you have it because by
by two uh a was in the class since a
prime is equivalent to a a prime is in
the class by by three since they have
the same count B Prime is in the class
but B Prime is also more equivalent to
be so based in the class so you go back
and forth this way so that's the quick
outline of the proof I'm almost out of
time so it's time to end uh what have we
seen here we have seen in summary that
common multiple interesting relaxations
of isomorphic isomorphism there are sub
differ differences in expressive power
between left profiles and right profiles
uh the last part we saw that homomoris
encounts give rise also to algorithms
for testing for membership in a class of
structures
and for the left query algorithms and
for classes that are closed under
homologous equivalence uh counting
doesn't buy you more than existence that
was a surprising result for us at least
two General open problems we
it started a little bit
right query algorithms over the Boolean
we don't know if we have a similar
result like the one I present at the end
if there is a difference between
counting and existence and
for right query algorithms but let me
finish with something sort of more
ambitious and at least more like of a
dream for me uh
can we characterize the logics
for which L equivalence in
distinguishability in the logic is
captured by a restricted left or by
restricted right profile
what is going on here well
for 40 years
a few hundred meters from here where is
alfredarski in the math department from
1942 until he's back in 1983. and parsky
in 1950 gave an an address in the
international Congress of mathematicians
and he made the case why you should
develop model Theory
and his goal was to characterize Notions
of meta mathematical origin in purely
mathematical terms and much of the word
model Theory from the time on is exactly
in this period how do we take Notions
that are uh
phrased in terms of logical terms
and we characterize them in purely
mathematical terms example concrete
example is the task keywords theorem
that a collection of structures is
defined by a formula first or the logic
event only if it's closed on the
subtractions or the kisler theorem the
two
structures are first order equivalent
different only have if and only if they
have isomorphic Ultra Powers one notion
is purely logical the other experience a
break so in some sense I would like to
think that this business of homomorphine
accounts is an evolutionary continuation
of a tasks program by other means thank
you very much
[Applause]
foreign
27 please
yes
so I think there is also the three
depths so three depth what is the status
of that
yeah so what's the status is it left can
do it and right we don't know we don't
know don't know about the right
yeah I mean these are these are not the
only results there is another
spectacular result that if you put on
the left planar graphs
then you characterize quantum
isomorphism
that's a spectacular result and uh and
randomizomorphism we know now it's
undecidable right so some of these
equivalent relations are going to be
undecidable of course you expect that
but it's nice to see the arise from such
a natural restriction on planar drives
of this The Matrix and another two rows
are equal in North Dakota is there
an isolated characterized and those uh
that that do occur
s so for example if somebody gets less
price
yeah I don't know that's a nice question
thank you I don't know it may be none it
doesn't
so
uh sort of open-ended question about
homomorphism equivalence which you did
at the beginning and then at the end of
your talk I was wondering is there a
sort of model Theory or structure theory
behind this I I'm not familiar with the
theory of that so
um
there is I mean even
one of the results that we we used in
the first characterization where I
mentioned uh rosman's rosman's theorem
he basically turns uh a version of a
morphe equivalent to
when the fire depth equivalence at a
higher level I mean so that's that's an
interesting connection between the two
Notions and that's what that's what we
needed that's one of the results that I
know so maybe an example question would
be is there take a class of home a more
homomorphism equivalent structures and
um or a a largest class of home or
physical structures does it have a
minimal element or is there or something
they were in the examples you gave at
the beginning for instance um
yes I think uh this this is this should
be some of this would be in the book by
Helen nezatril they have studied the
there is an order there is an order and
you can cite the properties of this
order and a lot of it is known but I
can't give you a complete answer now
okay thank you
graph and homomorphisms disorders
difference
we have this result
having the same Spectrum
yes but there's also having the same
Spectrum Matrix
results
I don't know I have not seen anything
about it
okay
um I guess on that note let's conclude
uh thanks a lot okay
coffee break now and we meet again at
11.
all right